well bjorn ulvaeus joins us now
it's quite frankly amazing to talk to
you bjorn thanks for joining us this
morning
um look tell us it's a pleasure stephen
tell us about this report and just how
concerned you are with the impact the
pandemic has had on
on royalties for artists
well in a funny way it it has
put the focus on the plight of
songwriters because
artists suddenly found themselves in the
same place
as songwriters have been for a long time
that is
trying to make a living out of streaming
which is very very difficult
and the core of
of the music industry for me has always
been the song
um but somehow the songwriters have
always been
regarded as something in the periphery
rather than the star of the whole thing
so
what needs to change then within all of
this this is perhaps giving a bit more
focus onto the songwriters but in terms
of rebalancing the money
is that even possible
i think so and i think that there's a
movement
on both side of the atlantic now uh
i think that uh more and more people
realize that the ecosystem
is dysfunctional it it needs to be
so that no part is unhappy
and as it is right now more and more
songwriters have to drive ubers
uh because of of the imbalance
um and there are several factors in this
um there is the uh
way that royalties are calculated from
from streaming services um
which is uh you know they have they they
every month um the money goes into a big
pot
and then that is divided by the total
number of
clicks that month which means that
each click gets uh you know very very
little money
but most clicks go to the people who
have been
the mega players and
uh very little money goes to the people
underneath that absolute elite layer
and so what i propose is a kind of
user-centric a kind of fan centric model
in streaming where uh your description
your subscription goes exactly to the
people that you play
i mean in terms of the of the the
companies behind all this streaming i
mean
do you think they will be willing to
look at this is this a sort of change
they'd be happy to make
uh not happy to make perhaps but
it will be something they have to make i
think
because it used to be that
the elite songwriters of course could
always make a living out of songwriting
but there was a layer underneath as well
um and and they could make a living
during um
in the physical era and
they um could manage to
push themselves up to the upper level
uh through having you know the time
and being able to afford to spend time
on becoming better songwriters
and uh it's you know it's a talent
but it's also a craft and you have to
hone your craft
with that in mind i mean just how real
is the possibility then if it's
if it's just not paying enough money
under the the way the current system
works well we're
we're gonna miss out we're gonna miss
out on some real talent aren't we
i'm afraid so uh i mean i'm uh
i'm an example of what i
mean because before we won the
eurovision song contest with waterloo
benny anderson and i have been had been
in a rat race we were running around
producing
other people's records writing songs for
other people even going on
tours you know in different
constellations just to pay the rent
but from waterloo when the royalties
came
pouring in from that time we could
afford to say no to
everything else and just concentrate on
the writing
and that's when you get better at it and
that's what i wish for more songwriters
today
for in terms of the public in terms of
us as listeners to music
um do we pay enough then should we be
expecting to pay more
for streaming services because it is
cheap at the moment
it is very cheap and and this is a
legacy from the
beginning of of streaming when it
actually
saved the music industry from illegal
downloading
uh but it's time i think and i i
i i think that the the streaming
services
are thinking about um higher prices in
the future
because after all to get all the music
from
from the whole world from every century
for 9.99 is is you know very cheap
um i can't let you go without asking
about abba directly um because
people wouldn't forgive me my father
wouldn't forgive me
joe our cameraman who's a superfan would
not forgive me
um you have written music
which all these decades later
has stood the test of time that there
isn't much in the world of pop which
you can listen to in 2021 that still
sounds as fresh as
as the day it was released how on earth
did you manage that
yeah i you know it's it
i'm constantly amazed at that
and and really i don't know how it
happened
we we just recorded you know the songs
the best we could